[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Join me in welcoming
to the stage Giorgia Lupi
and Kaki King.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - KAKI KING]
KAKI KING: Thank you.
I will be 39 in August.
And what that means is
I will have been playing
guitar for almost 35 years.
I started when I
was really young.
And as you can see, I started
to do something differently
with the guitar as
a teenager and have
made a career out of doing
interesting things with it,
some more traditional, some more
unorthodox, like you just saw.
But the most interesting
thing that I did recently
was I started to incorporate
visuals into my live show.
So the show that I do is based
around a projection mapped
guitar--
so the light is only
hitting the guitar--
and a screen behind me,
and I am in silhouette,
and I'm almost a
character that ceases
to exist, other than to
serve the purpose of playing
the guitar.
So because of this show-- it's
called "The Neck is a Bridge
to the Body"--
I found myself falling
into worlds that I never
thought I would,
such as the design
world, and the performing arts
world, and the sort of more
theatrical world.
And through this,
I was introduced
to very different people.
Not just musicians, but
designers, and thinkers,
and software
engineers, and people
who were just fascinated
with what I was doing,
one of whom was a person
that introduced me
to the amazing woman
sitting here, Giorgia Lupi.
His name is John Mayeda,
and you may know him.
And Giorgia's going
to talk a little bit
about our
collaborations and what
we've done since we've met.
And we're going to sort of
continue the conversation.
Welcome, Giorgia Lupi.
[APPLAUSE]
GIORGIA LUPI: Thank you.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Giorgia.
And I'm collaborating with my
dear friend, and as you hear,
the super talented
musician Kaki King.
But I'm not a musician myself.
I work with data.
And we will explain
you and show you
what we are doing together
in the space of data, music,
and data visualization.
But let me take a step back and
share with you who I am first.
I work with data in my day job.
I'm one of the partners
and the Creative Director
at Accurat, a small data
visualization design firm
that we started in Milan,
Italy, which is my home country.
And now I also
have a small office
in New York, where I live.
And yeah, this is
our talented team
of designers, and data
analysts, and developers.
They say "hi" from Milan.
And we're missing some
of them in this picture,
as it was taken a little ago.
But we hardly are
in the same place,
so that's the more complete
pictures that I have.
So every day, I am, and we
are, presented with challenges
on how to make sense of a
complex system of informations.
And with my team, we
address, we frame them,
and we solve them through
visual representation.
So we work with very different
clients, clients in the IT,
even with tech companies
like Google itself,
but also with many
non-profits and organizations
to create tools and
visualizations that
can make data accessible, both
to their internal and external
audiences.
And I will give
you a few example
of the type of challenges that
we are presented with every day
to give you a sense, from
working with organizations
such as IBM, re-imagining how
the whole organization uses
data visualization on
all of their products
and how they can work with data
effectively on a daily basis.
So design first, a
practical guide on how
to translate numbers into charts
in the very different cases
they will encounter, but
also designing guidelines
for the creation of visuals with
data that will look and feel
like IBM, to collaborating
with the first Italian woman
astronaut, Samantha
Cristoforetti,
creating a live web experience
with the data of her mission
during her six month long
expedition to the International
Space Station.
And that was really
exciting indeed,
but where we actually
involve her funds directly
in the experience,
giving them the chance
to interact with her
as she was in space.
And to creating and
building real time tools
for social science researchers
that, through visualization,
can help them monitor
large-scale social experiments.
But I also do more
experimental work
and artistic work,
such as art commissions
or self-initiated
projects, where I mainly
try to explore and adopt a
broader definition of data,
accepting also the more
subjective intimate
and therefore imperfect aspects
of these information systems
that we live in.
I talk a lot about what
I called it a humanism.
That is my attempt to define
the focus of my research
and to understand what
my personal contribution
to the field of data could be.
And where here,
I try to advocate
that to make data
faithfully representative
of our human nature, we
need to start designing ways
to include empathy--
again, imperfection
and human qualities--
into how we collect,
process, and display data.
And this is really
what guides my work.
The project that I'm
probably most known for
is called "Dear Data," a
year-long collaboration
with another information
designer, Stefanie Posavec.
That was, for me, the
big data hangover cure.
Stefanie and I only
met twice in our life,
where we decided to run
this very radical experiment
around one main question,
is it possible to get
to know another human
being through data only?
So for what we called
"Dear Data," every weekend
for one year, we used
our personal data
to get to know each other.
Every week and for one year,
we would collect personal data
around weekly shared mundane
topics, from our thoughts
and ideas, to the interaction
with our partners,
to the compliments that
we gave and received,
to our most intimate feelings,
so 52 excuses in form
of data to investigate and
reveal aspects of ourselves
in our lives, personal data
that we would then manually
hand draw on a postcard size
sheet of paper that every week,
we would send from London
to New York where I live,
and from New York to
London, where she lives.
And I'm always so jealous
of the red London post box
when I show these
slides, compared
to the creepy [INAUDIBLE]
in New York and [INAUDIBLE]..
So every Monday
and for one year.
So the front was always the
data drawing and the back
of the postcard
contained, of course,
the address of the other
person, but also the legend,
how to interpret our drawings.
And so we started looking
at our days through data,
but not only quantifying
the numbers of times
we would perform
a certain actions,
instead adding
context or details
about why what was
happening, what
was the situation
and the feeling,
realizing really, week after
week, how to put ourself
in these numbers and how
the context of our very
personal stories,
for the moment,
was as important, if not more,
than the activity we were
counting, if we wanted
to make this data truly
meaningful and
representative of ourselves.
We've investigated our minds
and our most intimate thoughts
and fears through data,
sharing with the other person
all the moments we felt--
anxious, sad,
frustrated, fearful,
and explaining why
through the way
we categorized our
moments of negativity.
And ultimately, as we say,
we have been using data
as our unique language,
really as our alphabet,
to discover and communicate
our lives to the other person
for one year.
After the project, Stefanie
and I worked on a book
where we illustrated
all of the lessons
that we've learned
in life and data.
And "Dear Data" has been
exhibited around the world.
And then to our incredible
joy and surprise,
it's found the
most exciting home,
as the original set
of our cards has
been acquired as part of
a permanent collection
of the Museum of Modern Art.
But what excited us
even more is that
what really made us
want to explore further
this idea in our jobs, which is
also what I'm doing with Kaki,
is that "Dear Data" has
been so well received
from the public outside
the data community.
We've seen really
thousands of postcards
made by people who
learned about the project
and wanted to experiment
on themselves,
and even teachers of any
grade using this format
to teach their students
the world of data.
It has, in a way,
opened the idea
of data to really a
wider audience that
made it more
approachable, a tool that
can be useful for
everyone and not
only for who already
work with data
or is keen to self-tracking.
And I really ask myself, why did
this project resonate so much
outside the data community?
And I feel it's because
it showed that data is not
interesting, or boring,
or scary, or big
per se, but it's really a
tool in medium [INAUDIBLE]
and a material that is
actually out there for everyone
to use in many different ways.
And this is what guides
all of my projects,
whether they are purely
artistic projects--
this is a data visualization
that was up at MoMA
last fall, closing Paola
Antonelli's last exhibition
"Items--
is Fashion Modern?"-- I don't
know if you got the chance
to see the exhibition,
where I didn't have
any data besides the list
of the 111 items of clothing
and accessories included in the
show and the research material
put together by the curators.
And this was another
project where activity
builds my data sets by asking
systematic questions that I
was reading as I was reading
and studying the taxonomies.
But I'm not going to
talk about my projects
today, though you can find
all of them on my website.
I wanted to give you a sense of
my approach to data in general
before talking about
our collaboration,
because it's also what
I'm using in our work.
So Kaki and I started
working together
when design guru John Mayeda,
who, again, you might know,
called us to collaborate on the
new brand identity for the 200
years anniversary of a
limited edition for Hennessy,
the cognac brand, where we
designed a visual identity made
of music and data visualization.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And this is, of
course, Kaki playing.
And so starting from a trip
that Kaki took to Cognac,
Kaki composed the 200 beats
song to hundreds of the 200
years of the limited edition.
And then I dissected and
analyzed every single movement
that Kaki does with her
hands as she plays this song.
And this is--
KAKI KING: Every
single movement.
GIORGIA LUPI: It was
kind of laborious, Yeah.
KAKI KING: Yeah, it was
incredibly laborious.
Yeah, so normally when you
have music, you have notation.
With guitar, you
can have tablature,
which is a map of the
neck of the guitar,
where to place your hands.
But in this case, it was
if the left hand index
finger swipes up
on this beat, that
is its own symbol, as
opposed to the middle finger
of the right hand doing so.
I am still--
I mean, even after so
many collaborations,
I'm still floored that
you went to the length
that you did to
dissect what you did.
And the cool thing about
it-- as you're going to see--
it wraps around the box.
And it is a tribute to
the 200 years of VSOP.
GIORGIA LUPI: Yeah, my work
tends to get pretty detailed.
I tend to get very
obsessed with that.
KAKI KING: Your brain
is built for it, though.
GIORGIA LUPI: Yeah.
Well, I mean, so this is the
idea of the whole process.
And then visually,
I was taking cues
from Hennessy's visual legacy,
which is really done of all
of these calligraphy types.
And I plotted all of that
into this visual score,
where every vertical line is
one beat-- so again, 200 beats--
to create the visual
centerpiece of the branding
on this special edition.
And this is how it
looks like in the end.
So again, every
symbol that you see
is really the
representation of things
that Kaki does with her hands.
And I mean, I feel like-- and
we are starting to open up this
into a more
conversational thing--
I feel that the reason why
we decided to go this far
is that there's only
so much information
that can be told through
a score or a tablature.
And especially in
Kaki's case-- and you've
heard how she plays--
there is a lot that
can be really transformed.
KAKI KING: It's hard even
to transcribe what I do
and to make it as
specific as possible.
It's still very
difficult for people--
without seeing me do it or
having it explained to them,
it's hard for it
to just be placed
on a traditional notation
in tablature score.
GIORGIA LUPI: Yeah.
But then Kaki and I fell in
love with each other's work.
And we decided to keep
exploring together.
Early last year, we
guided an audience
of 2,000 people in
the Opera Theater
in Cape Town on how to see music
exactly as we were describing,
based, again, on a laborious
representation of what
Kaki does with her hands
on her guitar as she plays.
And actually in this case, where
both the song and the visuals
were informed by personal data
collection from our lives.
As I did into your data,
we also did it together
to compose a structure for
Kaki to interpret what we did
in our days and compose a song.
And this is the
visualization of the song
that she played live as
she guided the audience
to really understand
what every symbol means.
And just really quickly,
in every section,
the number of black lines
is the number of beats.
And the symbol above represents
the song being played,
where the top of the
flower is Kaki's left hand
and the bottom part
is her right hand.
And the position of the
colors and the dimensions
of the symbol represent
exactly the gestures
that Kaki does with her hands.
And it sounds like this.
[GUITAR MUSIC]
But then, unfortunately,
something not pleasant
happened.
And I'd like Kaki
to describe it.
KAKI KING: So Giorgia and I
had done these two projects
together, which, you know,
when you work on a project that
is as time-consuming
and laborious,
and back and forth, as it is,
you get to know each other,
even just doing one or two,
as was the case at this point.
And so I had a trust in
Giorgia that I turned out
would need, really.
My daughter, who at the
time was almost three
this last year-- this is
her in her hospital bed.
She was diagnosed with a very
strange autoimmune disorder
called ITP.
It's normally not
life-threatening.
But it causes your body to
attack its platelets, which is
essential for blood clotting.
So my daughter basically
woke up one morning
and had blood in her mouth.
She was just
spontaneously bleeding,
and it was terrifying.
This is her in the hospital
with her owl, her trusty owl.
Her arm is wrapped up
because she's having an IV.
She's actually having
a platelet transfusion.
She had two of those, and it
was absolutely terrifying.
It's a strange disorder.
It's very, very weird when you
are told that your daughter's
body is attacking itself.
If it's something from the
outside, it's like, OK, look.
We can fix this, we
can make sense of this.
But that's what's
happening inside.
And also, there's very few side
effects when children have it.
So she was fine.
She didn't have
fever or fatigue.
But you can show them
the next one, yes.
This is what was
happening to her body.
Spontaneously, these
types of bruises
were coming up everywhere.
My son had been born
just a few weeks earlier.
So we had a new
baby and a daughter
with a very strange illness.
So the family was
kind of separated.
I stayed in the hospital
with my daughter.
And I just watched these
bruises appear on her body.
But a few weeks into the
process, she was sent home.
She had medications.
We were told, you know,
don't let her hurt herself.
Don't let her fall off the--
I mean, she's a very
rambunctious child.
So that was hard.
I started to collect data.
Because I knew
that this was a way
to keep track of what was
happening with her, but also,
I think, that it really
became more about me.
Because I was losing my--
I was not parenting
well, I was not
coping well, and collecting
data on my daughter,
on her medications,
on her bruises,
on all of these things.
And then at the end
of my data collection
was the annotations part,
with basically the information
I had about myself.
And I recognized that.
So we would go back to the
doctor, get her platelet count,
get her number.
And I would base my
life off of that number,
whether I was happy
or sad, or able
to deal with some other
issue or not, or I had to--
and I connected my emotions
and my stability to this number
that, for my daughter,
really wasn't--
it wasn't affecting her.
She was still happy,
and she was energetic.
And she just happened to
have this thing that she was
hopefully going to grow out of.
So the data collection
we did really
helped me disconnect
from what was happening
to her medically versus what was
happening to her emotionally.
GIORGIA LUPI: Yeah.
So I mean, if you
think about it,
ITP is a very visual disease.
And in this moment
of uncertainty,
what Kaki was doing, and what I
was trying to support her with,
is define a structure for how
to observe what was happening.
And so she started
the daily observation
of a mix of quantitative
and qualitative information,
really bringing together
the clinical inputs
from Cooper's lab tests together
with much more soft data,
if we want to think data-wise,
from Kaki's observation
and from her life.
And we did so primarily to
channel stress and anxiety
into a semblance of control.
But also, as a step further
in our collaboration,
we decided to share
this story, the story
of the fourth month of data
collection, through data only.
And as I was reading
Kaki's records,
I was really
overwhelmed by feeling.
And the things that
I asked myself,
as a person who then worked
with data as a material
to build a narrative,
can that data
visualization evoke also
empathy and activate,
as in the people
who looks at that,
also at an emotional level and
not only at a cognitive one?
And can looking at
a data visualization
make you feel part of a
story of a human life?
So then I'll guide you
through the process
of the visualization.
And then we'll tell
you more about it.
I structured this
fluid timeline,
where each white element--
we can call them petals--
is a different day, for
a total of four months
of data collection.
And as Kaki was
anticipating, the time
that is structured in
sections are the moments
in between the
readings, meaning when
Cooper was admitted
to the hospital
to have her blood checked.
Because this moment
really paced their days.
And so the timeline
of the months
was not linear in their life.
And every time
there is a lab test,
we start a new group of petals.
And the platelet counts
from the lab tests
are represented
by these red dots
at the beginning of
each group of days.
And we need to say
that the normal range
for a platelet count
varies from 150 to 400.
And so the numbers
of 1, 7, and 30
that you see in the beginning
are really frightening.
And then I began to
incorporate Cooper's skin
as was observed by Kaki.
The intensity of the
bruises is represented
by these purple and
green splotches.
Of course, the more
intense and present,
the more they were present
that day on Cooper's skin.
KAKI KING: And sorry to jump in.
But those were really
hard things to quantify.
And I knew that, again,
my trust in Giorgia
was that I could say, you
know, these bruises are bigger
or they're more purple.
What happens when
you have a bruise
and you have ITP
is your platelets
don't rush in to help
the clotting process.
So you sort of bleed
into your bruise.
And an old bruise
can even become new
if your platelet count drops.
The blood simply
starts to leak out.
And there's also
these things-- and I
know you're about to speak
about them-- but petechiae.
And they're basically
just burst blood vessels
under the skin that can
also happen spontaneously.
Normally, if you scrape yourself
and don't break the skin,
you might get a few,
but they go away fast.
There would just be this
horrible rash on her neck,
on her face.
So yeah, it was a very
visual disease, but one that
was really hard to measure.
And so I had to use descriptive
words, rather than numbers,
at times.
GIORGIA LUPI: Yeah.
And when I was reading
these, I was not, of course,
interested in exact numbers
of bruises in petechiae,
but about the four
month of data collection
and the evolution of
all of this over time.
And so I took my own ways to
measure the intensity based
on the top, the day
that they were higher
and the day that
they were lower.
And I tried to use these
strokes and brushes that
can resemble visually the
disease in a way that also
helped us quantify the
data and really see
the picture, or the big
picture, that you're seeing
over a longer period of time.
Well, by then, we added
details about when
Cooper was taking medication--
steroids, specifically--
and they are these grape
shapes that affects the day.
Also, Cooper had some incidents,
such as she fell at the park
while playing or she got
bitten by a mosquito, that
caused her skin to worsen.
And we wanted to see how
that affected the skin,
so we also included that.
And you see how these fluid
timelines begin to take form
and to visually tell the
story of these months.
And again, as Kaki
was describing,
besides medical
data, there's also
what was going on in Kaki's
life and in her mind.
She tours a lot.
And she felt very
stressed when away
from home in this
particular period of time.
And the days that
she was gone are
indicated with these black dots
on the days that she was gone.
There also have been, luckily,
positive moments in these four
months, such as a fun
birthday party for Cooper
or her brother, or a
great Halloween night,
that I represented as these
bright yellow spots that
cheer up the visual, in a way.
And lastly, Kaki also kept track
of her level of hope and fear
for the day that she reported
on a scale from 1 to 10
for both emotions, and
that here are visualized
through the floating
lines framing the days,
where the dark
lines are her fears
and the orange
line are her hopes.
And as she was describing,
this whole process
is not only about
Cooper, but it's mostly
about Kaki, and her
life, and their feelings.
And all around, we had some
bits of Kaki's personal notes
for the day.
And this is the final artwork.
And ultimately, these data
also became, of course,
a piece of music that she
composed directly from the four
months of data collection.
And I don't know if
you want to explain it.
But this is the score that--
KAKI KING: This is
my score to help
me analyze the data
that I had written down
and to create a piece of music.
So these are all the measures.
So I believe we did each beat--
no, each measures is a day.
GIORGIA LUPI: Yeah, and
the song is 120 measures,
covering the 248 and 20
days of data collection.
And the timeline of
the song is exactly
representing what was
happening in their life,
exactly, as the
data visualization.
Yeah, there are elements
in the song that
reference the amount of
petechiae on Cooper's skin,
Kaki's changing mood.
And the main guitar
part is a musical map
of the bruises on Cooper's skin.
KAKI KING: This is
a really hard one.
It was really hard.
And even now, having some
distance, looking back,
I'm like, whoa, this is a very--
but again, I owe
this all to you.
Because this was a way--
like, the only way through--
the only way out was through.
And this is
something that I felt
necessary to do in order
to share it with people,
but also to create
something that was positive.
GIORGIA LUPI: So we
premiered this project
at a closed conference
of health care executives
in San Francisco
in January, where
Kaki played the song live.
And we're going to
play the song for you
here through this video.
And we invite you to get
immersed in this data
and to see if you feel
something through data only.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
So that is pretty intense.
But for the purpose
of talking about it
and sharing it with you,
as you can probably see,
this is not by any means a
scientific representation
of data.
But still, we think
that it paints
a pretty complete and sensorial
picture of these very personal
journeys.
And really, this type of
overlooked information--
what's going on in people's
lives, their feelings--
might be as important
as clinical data and lab
tests to frame a
disease, especially
from the point of view of the
patients and their family.
And after we released
the project publicly,
we received really
a lot of messages,
very personal messages, from
parents, caregivers, health
care practitioners, and in
general, human beings that
were deeply moved by this story
that we only told through data.
Many practitioners,
they mentioned
that they realize for the
first time that data could be
[INAUDIBLE] and used in
this way, many sharing how
the project really made them
think about data differently
in their work.
And they are starting
to think about how
to include other types of
data that they can measure
with the more human side.
Kaki and I are keeping
on to explore together.
And we will have some news soon.
I feel we'll also now like to
open it up to a conversation.
And for those of you
who are wondering,
Cooper is fine now, right?
KAKI KING: Cooper is OK.
She still has ITP.
She's still probably-- we're
unsure whether or not she
will grow out of it entirely.
This is her and her baby
brother a few months ago.
But she has been in a
healthy and fairly high
range, although not
in a normal range,
for platelet counts
for several months now.
So she hopefully will be fine.
And hopefully-- as
a childhood disease,
typically children
grow out of it.
She has had it
for almost a year,
and therefore they're a little
skeptical whether or not
it's going to stay.
But it's manageable.
It's manageable.
Yeah, thanks Giorgia.
GIORGIA LUPI: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: So I would
like to personally
say thank you for
sharing this story
and for coming and
not only sharing
your musical art with
us, but visual art,
and dealing with data.
And in watching this, I'm
reminded of Neil Gaiman's
speech about make great art.
No matter what comes along,
no matter what you face,
make great art.
And this is a perfect
example of what
seems to be great art coming
out of a difficult situation.
KAKI KING: I agree.
I mean, I think
that when I see--
every time the-- it's
never been easy to--
it's never been easy
to witness this.
And certainly, this is not
the first time I've cried.
But when everything
pans out at the end
and you see the full artwork,
and especially when I
see the printed art, I
think, that's so beautiful.
And it does change
my emotional state
from something that's
just filled with anxiety
and tenseness to wow,
at the end of the day,
we were able to make
something that's
really healing and beautiful.
And you know, I owe everything
about that to Giorgia.
GIORGIA LUPI: I was
only a supporter here.
KAKI KING: That's not true.
SPEAKER 1: But there's also just
this incredible density to it.
Not just the data
set, but the way
that it's layered, and the
artwork, and then the density
in the music.
And it, in an interesting
way, reflects the music
that you've always been making,
which is incredibly dense
and almost needs, as you kind of
alluded to before, to be seen.
Hearing it almost
undersells the importance
of what's actually going
on, the whole package.
KAKI KING: And I think that's
the strength of Giorgia
and our work together is that
alone, my music is what it is.
Alone, her artwork
is what it is.
It's both very good.
But together, we're able
to make something that's
very, very intensely powerful.
I think any time you merge
visual and musical information,
there's always an increase
in the emotional content
and people's ability to
connect and to have feelings.
But I think when you
understand that there
is a data point underlying every
single piece of information
that you're seeing and
hearing, that there's
a system and a logic
to it, it brings
it even more strength and
something solid to stand on.
Not to say art is
random, but it can be.
It can be more however
the wind blew that day.
But this is something that's
beautiful and very grounded.
GIORGIA LUPI: Just
to add on to that,
I feel that again,
the reason why we like
collaborating and we feel that--
yeah.
It's really good for
us to work together
is that both your music and
my way of visualizing data--
again, as you pointed
out in the beginning--
are very dense and very
rich, very detailed.
KAKI KING: They
complement each other.
GIORGIA LUPI: I
feel that, you know,
if I was probably a person
who worked with data in a more
standard way, and if
you were a musician who
worked with music in a
more standard way, probably
we still would get along.
SPEAKER 1: I know
you mentioned--
this composition, the
music that's underlying,
is based around the data.
Out of curiosity,
have you looked
at examining other
massive data sets
to see what they sound like?
KAKI KING: Well, it's tricky.
And I mean, even the
previous things that we've
done together, it's very--
music wants to have rules.
And it wants to
fit into a much--
you know, typically, the
scale has seven notes.
There isn't an infinite
amount of options.
There are many, many textures,
and styles, and colors.
But one thing that
we talk about a lot
is how music is something
that develops over time.
And now, you've always
said data does too.
GIORGIA LUPI: Yeah,
especially a data collection
that you do on your cell phone
on-- anything in the world
develops over time.
KAKI KING: But it's also
potential to stack data
like this.
And it's trickier to
do that with music,
to sort of say, well, I've got
30 data point, which you can
easily sort of show in a line.
But to put those 30 data
points into a musical note
or a musical measure--
it's a lot harder.
So I guess what I'm saying
is trying to work within
the parameters of
music in general--
even pretty far out ideas
and work with data sets is
challenging--
but it's also feasible and
something that we're taking on.
GIORGIA LUPI: Yeah,
we're collaborating.
We will have some news soon.
Hopefully, something big.
KAKI KING: We're
going to have a baby.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: A beautiful,
artistic baby.
Wonderful.
Let's take some questions
from the audience, please.
AUDIENCE: Hello?
KAKI KING: Yes.
AUDIENCE: First off,
thanks for coming, again.
And so a lot of creative
projects, pretty much everyone
that I know of, where
you're collaborating,
there's often disagreements.
And I was wondering,
especially when
it's something so personal,
you might bite your tongue.
And if maybe one person has an
opinion about the other one's
expertise, it's
harder to talk about.
But I was just wondering
if you could tell us
any stories about that, if
there was any disagreements.
KAKI KING: You know, in
this particular case,
I was still so distraught
that I needed guidance.
And I feel, for the most part--
and you'll have to correct me.
Because my memory, even
of this time period--
it's very cloudy.
My son, unfortunately, also
had an issue with his heart.
So just having two sick
children is more than--
it's really difficult.
So I looked to
Giorgia for guidance.
And I really didn't step in the
way of anything, unless I did.
Did we have a fight?
GIORGIA LUPI: No.
Honestly, I feel that we
never had a fight at all.
KAKI KING: But we have had our--
we're different though.
GIORGIA LUPI: We're
different, yeah.
KAKI KING: We're
very, very different.
We have different styles
and different approaches.
Even today, how many emails
did you send me about today?
And I was like, Giorgia,
it's going to be fine.
We're just going to do our
thing, speak to people.
And you're like, Kaki,
I have to have my notes.
GIORGIA LUPI: Well.
It's different.
I mean, I do public
speaking the whole time.
But since I don't
have a guitar with me,
and you don't have a structure.
And she's more like, whatever.
Because I'll play and I'll talk.
KAKI KING: I think that
we do approach our work--
and I've been performing on
stage for my entire career.
That's all my career has
ever been, since I was 23.
So I have a different
approach to most things,
really, just
getting things done,
not worrying about
their presentation, kind
of not thinking that this
project is the last thing that
will ever matter, just
sort of working through it.
And you are so precise, down to
every-- like, look at her work.
It is down to every
single last detail.
GIORGIA LUPI: You make
me sound very boring.
KAKI KING: No, I'm not
making you sound boring.
Because I don't know, trust me.
Because I respect
you, and in this way,
love you so much
because I'm not that.
I don't worry about the details
because in live performance,
it's gone.
The mistake is
forever forgotten.
I mean, really.
You just roll on
to the next gig.
And for you, what you
do is your legacy.
And it stays.
And there can be no mistakes.
And there can be no
something accidental.
Because again, what
data works-- sorry,
what Giorgia works with--
this is data.
What data works with is Giorgia.
That's really the truth.
So I think that
sometimes, because we
are working intimately
together on things,
our personal style-- like,
she'll send me 10 emails.
And I'm like, [LAUGHS]
I'll reply eventually.
I don't know.
I'm on tour.
What do you want?
But no.
I think we meet halfway.
And I think that I am inspired
by Giorgia's attention
to detail and her sort of
relentless Giorgianess,
if I can, getting both at
the data and representation
of the data perfectly,
but also the data
humanism, the beauty of it.
Those are the things that
inspire me about you.
GIORGIA LUPI: Well, thank you.
But I feel yours is really
an interesting question,
especially because as
I met Kaki personally--
it was right about after
the "Dear Data" project--
it was another
intense collaboration
with another woman.
And I feel that the
difference is there.
For example, if I had to compare
these two collaborations, which
are both amazing, and I have
two amazing friends out of that,
but is if you're collaborating
with a person who does exactly
what you do, it's harder.
Like, with Stefanie,
it has been way harder.
KAKI KING: Really?
GIORGIA LUPI: It is.
Oh, my god, yes.
You have no idea.
KAKI KING: She's talking
crap about her ex.
GIORGIA LUPI: We have.
[LAUGHTER]
No, no.
We share this on stage as well.
Stefanie and I
arrived to a point
where we really needed
to have a shared
spreadsheet of the
things that we hated
about each other's design so
that we didn't, like, you know,
by mistake pick
a font or a color
that the other person
didn't like in the book,
in the website.
So you have no idea what a
collaboration that doesn't work
looks like.
But I'm really, really
excited about I'm still
collaborating with Stefanie.
But I guess what I'm saying
is that what you and I do
is so different.
For me, collaborating
with you is
having a source of data,
a source of inspiration,
a source of really
things that are not
even comparable to my work.
This is really a fool
to my work in a way.
And I also believe that
our personalities--
we really also joke about that.
I send you pictures of
my perfectly organized
and color-coded drawers
and folded things.
KAKI KING: We do
have that in common.
I have two children,
and I have a wife
that works in set design, so
our house is just whatever.
I mean, it's a disaster.
GIORGIA LUPI: When
you need to breathe,
I can send you
pictures of my house.
KAKI KING: And when I need
to breathe, I ask Georgia,
can you just send me a
picture of your pens, just
your organized pens?
And I get these
beautiful photos.
And I get so calm.
And then I threaten her.
I'm like, I'm going to send you
a photo of my medicine cabinet.
[LAUGHTER]
So yeah, we do like clean
and organized things.
We do have that in
common, for sure.
And I think that ultimately,
I think we like our lives
to be clean and
organized and our work
to be powerful in that way.
So no.
No giant fights yet.
But definitely, certainly
different personalities,
but probably that have
arisen from the work
that we've been in for so long.
And I think my music and touring
has shaped who I am, for sure.
GIORGIA LUPI: Of course.
I mean, and I, on my hand-- and
then we'll change the subject--
but I work with clients.
Every time, I need
to be organized
and precise with emails,
with deadlines, with stuff.
I mean, it's really
different, probably,
to be a musician, and
touring the world,
and to run a company,
and working with data.
So it's kind of, really, the
opposite end of the spectrum.
But still I feel, again,
we meet in the middle.
SPEAKER 1: Well, on the
topic of organization--
and I think we do have a couple
more minutes for questions.
If anybody else, please
make your way to a mic.
On the topic of
the organization,
it makes me curious about
with the flowers project.
When you saw that
visually represented,
how did you process
that's what you're doing?
Because you talk about
not really fussing over
the details.
When you see it laid
out and so detailed of,
like, yeah, that's your
finger moving, that's
this other finger and this.
How did that impact you?
KAKI KING: I think it
is such an exciting--
I feel honored that what
I do is interesting enough
to know the person, not just
to learn it on the guitar,
or not just to be
curious about what it is.
But to be able to take
the time to work out
exactly what it is that
each finger on each hand
is precisely doing.
And the result is beautiful.
For me, when I look
at Giorgia's work,
it's about the
result. Again, I'm not
the most detailed person.
So you can read
the legend, you can
see exactly what's happening.
You can decipher it all.
It's all built on something
with this-- you know,
it all exists in the real world.
But that is less
important to me than what
has come out of it, which
is this glorious picture
of these beautiful, strange
flowers that have opened up.
So it's hard for me to
believe that that's my music,
that literally,
that is my music.
That is Giorgia's
interpretation of,
but that it's every
single thing that I do
is contained in that
visual representation.
So I think it's just this--
it's awe.
I'm just in awe of
both my sheer luck
that I get to work with
someone that cares enough.
that It resonates.
Every time you go to a
conference and you present it,
you're like, Kaki,
people loved it.
It was great.
GIORGIA LUPI: That's so true.
KAKI KING: Yeah.
And not being a person
that has any origin,
individual or tech world,
at all to be invited in
and to be having my music
expressed in this way is just--
I'm floored, I'm honored.
And it's just very special.
GIORGIA LUPI: But you
started to work with visuals
even before meeting me.
So I guess that you
were already drawn
into making your music not
only listenable, but also--
KAKI KING: It's true.
I had been starting
to work with visuals.
But the connection was
very soft, and not this--
GIORGIA LUPI: Yeah, not data.
KAKI KING: Not
data driven, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Well,
and I think it's
a great nexus of a lot of
different wants, and needs,
and weird triangulation
way, in that musicians
forever have sought
to make music
videos to have a visualization.
And people in the big
data world are like, well,
if it's just a bunch of
numbers, it's very dry.
So how do you make that
visually interesting,
or just interesting beyond
people who really like numbers?
And this seems to be a
great triad nexus of music
meets visual meets data.
And it's presented in a truly
awesome and awe-inspiring way.
So thank you very much, both.
We do have a couple of minutes.
Would you mind gracing
us with another song?
Oh, did you have
another question?
Yeah, absolutely.
AUDIENCE: I'd prefer hearing
another song, actually.
SPEAKER 1: I think
we got time for both.
Please.
AUDIENCE: First of all, thank
you both for being here.
Kaki, I was just wondering if
you could share a little bit
about how you normally approach
writing songs from scratch,
and then how it's different
to approach this song,
where you have these parameters
set out for you, where
if this data point represents
a percussion to hit here,
you sort of have to follow
that through for the rest
of the song.
KAKI KING: So when I
write a song from scratch,
I have total freedom.
Tempos, moods,
tunings, whatever--
I have no parameters, which
can be its own challenge.
With this tune, like I said,
sort of cramming data in--
I want to say cramming.
But when I get frustrated,
that's how I feel.
Because I feel like I'm not
servicing the data in the way
it should be.
And then there's certain musical
elements that just need to be--
there's a timeline.
There should be a beat.
There has to be an
opening and closing point.
So we did four months
of data because that
would fit into a
three minute song
with each measure being
three beats and 120 measures.
But basically, we had to cap
it to allow it to make sense
visually and musically.
And so for instance, there is a
part where my mood would shift,
and the piano sound
would go from a major
to a minor, or the
underlying synthesizer sound.
And I wasn't exactly
happy with it
because occasionally,
it wouldn't
happen in a four bar phrase.
It would sort of happen in
a bar five or a bar seven.
And even though I'm hip to
that, it wasn't always working.
So without shifting anything,
I nudged a little bit.
I sort of did that.
So trying to retain all of
the integrity of the data
and retaining the
integrity of music
is actually hugely challenging.
And that's something that
I think that I'm still
figuring out the process of.
GIORGIA LUPI: If I
can add one thing.
Following you from afar as
you were composing the music--
like, not from afar,
but from the outside--
is not that you
decided what notes
to play based on the data.
But you had some melodies in
mind, or melodies that like,
let's say,
combinations of sounds
that then would integrate
the timelines and the data
collection.
So it was not really a direct
translation of data a note,
G minor or something.
But it was more
like, OK, following
some structures, knowing
that there are some sections,
and moments that needed to
be represented with a sound
to really pay the truth
to the data collection.
But there were
moments when I feel
it's not that you
were improvising,
but that you took a fair amount
of freedom in little phrases
to express also things that
were really personal for you,
like your changes of mood.
So I guess I'm saying
it's not really
always a direct translation,
but it's more like data that
informs the music composition.
Whereas with data
visualization, probably
also because it's
more formalized
and because people need
to understand and see--
well, data visualization--
it is a direct translation
of the data points.
KAKI KING: Well, but also what
you do and with your focus
on data humanism, it
allows me to look at data
and say, I have a feeling now.
So much of what you do--
with your data,
with other things--
has so much personal
emotion built into it.
And music is the
language of emotion,
especially instrumental
music, which
is a language I'm
very familiar with.
So it's almost like, is it more
important for this precise note
to land on this exact
measure to represent
when we were in the hospital?
Or is it more important
to you to feel that?
And I think that
the data humanism
aspect of Giorgia's
work and music
allows that
connection to be made,
allows that freedom to
take a tiny bit of liberty,
but still more effectively
getting the point across.
SPEAKER 1: Excellent.
Thank you.
Again, just absolutely
astounding work.
It's really beautiful.
It's really sonically
amazing and astounding.
And you both have
created something
amazing that I think people
in the world can grow from,
just watching.
And hopefully, it
does have that impact.
We look forward to what is next.
Are you able to tell us anything
about this art and music baby?
KAKI KING: Because of
the foray into performing
arts and theatrical
work that's still
based all around me
playing the guitar--
but I have a lot more
creative freedom and license--
and because of my
work with Giorgia,
there are arts organizations out
there who are basically saying,
we are inviting you to create
a work that incorporates what
I do, what Giorgia does,
and tells more of a story
through data.
Not just data visualization,
but to kind of address
all of what does that word do to
your mind and to talk about it.
And Giorgia has been--
I've sort of signified her as
my muse, and my consultant,
and as well as
someone that's going
to do a lot of visual
work for the show,
both in the things that
you've already seen
and hopefully, some ways
that we haven't tried yet.
GIORGIA LUPI:
Yeah. so it will be
hopefully a full show together.
Like with Kaki,
of course, that's
going to be the person
playing in 2019.
For me, it's also
real interesting
to take this idea
of data humanism
and bring it outside the data
community or the visualization
community, and try
to tell a story
of the many different ways
that we have to look at data.
And that data-- soft and
small, and big and cold--
influences our lives.
So that will be it.
KAKI KING: Stay tuned.
SPEAKER 1: Excellent.
Well, I'm certainly
looking forward to it.
And again, thank you very much,
both, for being here today.
KAKI KING: Thank
you for having us.
SPEAKER 1: And
absolutely, please.
The stage is yours.
KAKI KING: I will.
Here we go.
[APPLAUSE]
This song goes out to
my buddy Aaron over here
and also my buddy
Giorgia over there.
[MUSIC - KAKI KING]
[APPLAUSE]